[Music]
to me it's amazing some of the things
that we actually do know you know
there's plenty of things that are
conjecture or theories but there's a lot
of stuff that we have real observations
and real knowledge of and amazingly to
me one of the things is where did all
the atoms in our body come from and it
is actually a real fact not a theory
that when you look back at how the
universe looked about saved say 13
billion years ago the chemistry was very
very different we can actually see so
far away out into space that the light
were looking at took billions and
billions of years to get to us even at
the speed of light and the farthest away
we can see is to a time that was about
400,000 years after the Big Bang that's
pretty impressive that's about 13 and a
half billion years ago and when you look
back that far the only thing you see is
very hot hydrogen gas a little bit of
helium tying a bit of lithium but that's
it that's not theory that's actually an
observation and as you look at galaxies
very far away in space and therefore
very far back in time you can actually
watch the chemistry change you watch
different atoms get built up and the
only thing in the universe that we know
that can make a large atom by large I
mean something like oxygen or carbon or
calcium or anything that makes up our
bodies is actually the very core of a
star that's where nuclear fusion
reactions Ram hydrogen together the
hydrogen was formed during the Big Bang
you take these hydrogen atoms you smash
them together and you build larger and
larger atoms until you build something
like the carbon that makes up most of my
body
and so we've known for a while that the
only way you get these large atoms is
stars but even with something as
powerful as the core of a star there
were some atoms that were a little bit
more slippery we couldn't quite figure
out how you get the energy needed to
make something really big like a Gold
atom that should take even higher
temperatures even more energy than what
you typically find in the core of a
massive star so what is even more
violent than an exploding massive star
which makes a lot of the heavy elements
of the universe one of the things we
discovered recently is that two dead
cores of stars called neutron stars can
actually spiral together and core
and when they collide instead of a
normal death of an exploding star
you basically have something like that
on steroids you have an explosion that's
so big and so violent people have really
seen nothing like it since the Big Bang
they call this uh sometimes they call it
a hypernova sometimes they call it a
gamma-ray burst because of the bursts of
high-energy radiation that comes out but
wonderfully we've been observing more
and more of these colliding neutron
stars and they are just pumping out gold
atoms platinum atoms interesting enough
bismuth because these very very large
difficult to form atoms and there is so
much gold created in one of these
explosions that if you just look at the
rate you know how many of these
explosions do we observe amazingly we
observe about one a day and how much
gold is created in one of those and you
can actually account for the entire
abundance of gold in the universe just
from that one thing those colliding
neutron stars so the gold you have I
mean yeah you have gold in your jewelry
that's really cool I've got a gold ring
but innocently enough our neurons don't
work without a tiny little bit of gold
to help our brain actually charge the
neurons in our brain we need a little
bit of gold a little bit of copper so
your brain wouldn't work without a
little bit of gold a couple of gold
atoms in the neurons so the reason we're
here thinking and moving and actually
existing the way we do is intimately
connected to these colliding dead stars
these colliding neutron stars that most
likely created all of the gold in this
room
[Music]